all right fun topic fun topic
no matter how well you play it's hotness
that makes people pay
or it's a great website the Free Press
puts it the nc2a has a hot girl problem
and the problem is that we're paying
attention to attractive female athletes
you know the ones who don't have penises
that's a sticking point for me oh God
sorry I know I just came up with that
really yeah sometimes I just that was
written on your fridge
[Laughter]
turns out it's the best looking players
not the best athletes that earn the most
cash so it's appearance over substance
also known as the Mike Baker principle
yeah it's also all happening as a result
of a 2021 Supreme Court ruling which
allowed College athletes to finally make
money on their name image and likeness
well if anybody's sympathetic to cashing
in on your looks it's this collection of
hot ass
so with their exposure National audience
athletes can now utilize their Fame to
sell stuff at the Forefront or the
Cavender twins who doesn't love twins
who started earning endorsement deals
while playing basketball at the
University of Miami since graduating
they now make a living online thanks to
a massive social media following and
just being hot
I know the feeling
you should see the traffic on my MySpace
page
in fact tons of good looking female
college athletes are now making way more
than men critics say it sexist to
embrace objectification for profit but
shouldn't we be celebrating female
entrepreneurs
so there is in fact a hot girl problem
and it's that people have a problem with
hot girls myself included they won't
stay out of my hot tub a sexist would
say so let this let these attractive 22
year olds capitalize on their looks you
know they'll turn 30 soon enough and
it'll all be over
wow yet another sexist would say oh
gotta get rid of those guys bad
influence Michelle you're from the
Sports World yes
um isn't this how nature operates I mean
beauty is female currency status created
through strength there's male currency
that's just men don't care if you're the
best fencer Michelle no they don't they
don't but women care that Mike Baker's
the best fencer yeah I'm quite The
Swordsman yes you are
yeah this is this is this is capitalism
right so the fact that the NCAA didn't
see this coming or they say they didn't
see this coming is a joke like you open
this world up guess what you get to now
endorse Brands uh that maybe the hot
looking people would have a little bit
of an advantage I'm sure the hot men do
too but I will say there probably is a
double standard that the male athletes
who are really really talented and
skilled are probably going to get don't
look at me though don't you think
they're gonna get they're going to get
their endorsements but these women and I
saw a commercial last night for some
yoga wear and it was this college
gymnast and she was hot because you know
what yoga wear looks really good on hot
women yeah so therefore they wanted her
now there is this reaction from the NCAA
you know what maybe we should just pool
all the money and then divide it up
evenly between all the athletes wrong
that is socialism and you know the only
good thing that would come out of that
is these young people would finally
learn how lame and unfair socialism is
yeah ones who are scoring the most
points or doing the best aren't getting
the money now or just scoring or just
scoring touche it looks her thing Greg
yes they are tell me about I've had to
live with this for years
cat it's kind of funny though when you
think about it who cares about sports
right yeah I mean think about it plenty
of women are hot are making money they
don't need to play volleyball right hot
lady in the corner you the one that's
meeting me later yeah there's nobody
there I'm just kidding this article was
like really really long for the thesis
being if you're hot you'll make more
money on Instagram yeah
and it does drive me crazy though some
of these 22 year olds like some of the
endorsement deals that they get they're
like here's my secret to looking young
and beautiful and it's like a cream it's
like no just like post a picture of your
birth certificate
because you are yeah
it is
it's thing for young people to do so
easy and also
if you're not hot there's never been a
better time to pretend that you are yeah
like I don't look like this and then
also on Instagram there's the filters
you can edit everything I mean I've you
ever been out and seen any of these
people in real life they don't look like
that yeah and I'm not judging because
again same yeah you know uh Tyrus it is
really kind of a shame if you're young
you're not and you're not good looking
that's on you because you're at that
genetic High Point you should be
exploiting the way you look because it's
all downhill after 23. okay first of all
as a guy who doesn't wear makeup or
anything what you see is what you get uh
I think if these young women athletes
they're training they're busting their
ass they're dieting to look their best
they're playing at a high level and if
people want to
support them and buy their brands good
for them because you know what why are
they attacking them when they when you
can be 900 pounds on Instagram and put a
filter on and everyone wants to watch
the train wreck so is it that group
that's getting upset because they're
getting attention put away by and it's
always attacking women notice that
lately it's always women oh hot women
why are they hot because they're in
shape they got their butts into college
on scholarships and now people want to
buy their jerseys or whatever product
good for them because most athletes
Don't Go Pro most athletes don't have
that opportunity and even women that do
Go Pro they don't make that much money
because America feminist women don't
support their their professional careers
exactly so good for them just like guys
not every guy's going to the NFL yeah so
if you if you ever have a cool
weightlifting habit you clean a jerk
awesome and they which is weights gut
felt I know
and you want to put that up there and
get an endorsement for it good for you
this is this is a stupid article leave
them alone they're allowed to make money
and again some people think it's hot and
then somebody wants to watch the train
wreck this is America let them do their
thing
um uh we gotta go soon here Mikey but I
want you to keep it tight if you know
what I mean how uh how did being
handsome help you you probably cruised
through life didn't you you have to
worry about a damn thing well I make a I
make a ton of money on my only fans
account
and uh you drive it like a vintage
classic car shirtless I do yes I drive
my right hand drive MGB from 1965. for
all those gonna be best so but I will
say that to to tyrus's point look the
Cavender twins they were playing ball
for a D1 school yeah but you know how
few people get to play at that level one
of them averaged 12 points a game one
out of four points a game and you know
okay sure yeah are they high the course
they are and they're taking advantage of
that and that's the way the system works
right right so just to make it clear the
Cavender twins are that we're talking
about two people yeah
yeah yeah we're talking about so it's
twins so there's two of them it's like
the Polanski twins from my old high
school yeah God who can forget that you
probably would stay in great shape
though because if you have someone to
look exactly like you you want to be
like the fat one no exactly no you got
it twins just feed off their twinness
yeah yeah you can't get you can't go
gray before the other one you can't get
back you know and if one has more kids
than you then you have to kill their
kids oh God
this one weird
yeah I didn't see that coming yes well
that's the point of this show it always
ends in Murder just your boob again like
you did last night
boob hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else